(DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING
INTERMITTENTLY)
NARRATOR: In 2017,
HBO's biggest Sunday night show
returns.
(MUSIC STOPS)
Oh, wait.
Oh, I'm sorry.
-You meant...
-NARRATOR: Yeah, not you.
Right. It's just,
I heard your voice
-and I assumed--
-NARRATOR: I said biggest.
You did.
NARRATOR: But 2017
also brings you
the much awaited fourth season
of HBO's smash hit comedy...
(MUSIC STOPS)
Oh, again. I thought you were
talking about a different show.
-He said "hit comedy."
-I hear that now.
At best you are
an acquired taste.
-You have made your point.
-Sometimes we don't want
a British man yelling at us
about how the world is ending
for a whole hour.
Well, it's a half-an-hour show.
Doesn't feel like it.
(DRAMATIC MUSIC RESUMES)
NARRATOR: And finally,
it's the long awaited return
of the HBO show everyone's
been waiting for.
(MUSIC STOPS)
Oh, no.
Oh, you thought that
applied to you?
Yeah, I did. Because we've been
off for awhile. So...
Well, you know, five years.
Yeah, why have you been off
for five years?
LARRY DAVID:
I've been busy, okay?
What have you been doing?
Things.
NARRATOR: Last Week Tonight
With John Oliver.
-Don't even think about it.
-Sorry.
Returns Sunday, February 12th
on HBO.
Try it free.